[Musique]
et avec nous sur ce plateau pour en
parler gérald ollivier journaliste
chercheur associé à lips bonsoir gérant
du vivier merci d'être avec nous à nos
côtés également eugène berg ancien
diplomate bonsoir gène berg merci d'être
là alors tout malgré un l'annoncent bon
ça malgré l'annoncé par moscou de la fin
de certains je dis bien certains
exercices militaires moscou qui
semble-t-il calme le jeu aujourd'hui le
porte parole du pentagone affirme ce
soir que la russie a encore renforcé son
dispositif militaire aux frontières de
l'ukraine auourd'hui du week-end c'est
vrai qu'on a du mal à suivre gérald
olivier peut-être que vous qui
connaissez bien les états unis pouvez
vous nous éclairer sur quoi se basent
washington pour affirmer ce type
d'information leurs a priori ils ont des
renseignements qui sont assez précis
puisque comme le rappelait votre
reporter de quelques minutes ils ont
même la date de cette invasion à
mercredi 16 février ils n'ont pas
communiqué enfin certains éléments de
ces renseignements ont été communiqués à
certains organes de presse dont société
de presse et autres mais on n'a pas
véritablement le détail par contre il
est évident que d'un point de vue
diplomatique et d'un point de vue pour
la maison blanche ou même pour le
département d'état ils ont tout intérêt
à je dirais jouer les alarmistes c'est à
dire que si il s'avérait que les choses
tournent mal à la frontière ukrainienne
et il aurait tout loisir de dire on vous
avait prévenus et poutine apparaîtrait
comme l'agresseur si par contre il y a
des escalades ils auront tout loisir de
dire notre discours a été entendu et
donc nous avons eu gain de cause donc
ils auront gagné sur les deux tableaux
c'est à un point de vue qui permet d'une
certaine façon en même temps de m gla
demir poutine et la russie un petit peu
plus sous le spotlight est de faire en
sorte que s'il avait eu l'intention ce
qui n'a jamais été prouvée mais s'il
avait une intention véritable d'envahir
l'ukraine d'y réfléchir un petit peu à
deux fois avant de le faire mais sur le
plan diplomatique c'est du gagnant
gagnant pour eux que de faire monter la
tension et gelber vous avez le la même
analyse que gérald olivier du gagnant
gagnant pour les états unis au mieux ils
auront servi à faire la paix au pire on
voit ce que nous explique et faire le
vide est
bon c'est une interprétation c'est vrai
mais je crois que les américains
faisant adoptant cette attitude 1 hier
j'écoutais la télévision russe il s'en
amuse il se disait il c'est ce pourquoi
pas le 22 2 22 ça serait fantastique ce
serait vraiment un chiffre rond bon
soyons sérieux ça fait longtemps que ça
dure moi j'aimerais apporter un autre
une autre un élément au débat il faut
pas oublier que la russie est le premier
exportateur et pétrole elle fournit 40%
du gaz et finalement les états unis en
lançant cette espèce de de pressions
psychologiques et en alarmant mais ils
font monter les prix le brent et à 100
dollars aujourd'hui le gaz a multiplié
par 4 et la russie en train d'engranger
énormément des milliards de dollars
alors si j'étais américain bravo ils
sont en train de renforcer l'arsenal
financier de ce qu'ils appellent leur et
demi donc là aussi leur stratégie est un
peu à courte vue alors évidemment ça
c'est qu'un élément l'autre élément
effectivement vous la personne n'a
mentionné tout à l'heure j'ai écouté
quand même monsieur lavrov à la radio
russe ce matin à face après midi il a
une discussion avec ans avec monsieur
charles de gaulle mise la défense et
monsieur poutine d'ailleurs maintenant
il ya une expression à moscou le format
micro ou macro c'est à dire une grande
table et monsieur là j'ai entendu
monsieur poutine a demandé à son
ministre voyez c'est ouvert est ce que
vraiment on a épuisé les possibilités de
dialogue est bien le chef le vétéran la
diplômée un des vétérans de la
diplomatie mondiale a répondu avec son
solide bon sens en tant que diplomate je
dirais non et je pèse mes mots il a dit
non les possibilités peuvent être
prolongé et élargi
élargissez justement
je crois dans la tente de l'arrivée du
chancelier fédéral hall of fame à moscou
et on verra si effectivement ils seront
élargis donc il ya tous ces ce battage
médiatique d'une invasion mais il ya
également la négociation qui se prolonge
il peut-être qu'il va même s'élargir on
verra effectivement on l'a mentionné
tout à l'heure un ces mots plutôt
rassurant cette main en tout cas ce
geste tendu de de sergueï lavrov
justement on parler de désinformation ce
battage médiatique vous venez de dire
aux jeunes berg et on va regarder
certains titres de la presse américaine
a clairement elle a remis ça à l'instar
de son gouvernement je vous en laisse
découvrir certains cnn un très proche
l'euro s'est un peu plus tôt des
démocrates du gouvernement l'a réussi en
cercle l'ukraine sur trois côtés voici
d'où une invasion pourraient être lancés
alors etienne c'est carrément doux
l'invasion va être lancée politico les
états unis alerte sur la possibilité
d'une guerre imminente en ukraine ce
soir gérald olivier on apprend également
que l'ambassade des états unis est
transféré dans une autre ville que kiev
il ya également cette guerre de la
désinformation ça passe par là les
médias sont-ils entre guillemets
complice où ils ont des informations que
nous n'avons pas nous ça fait quand même
un certain temps que les médias
américains enfin ce qu'on appelle les
mines stream médias cnn en fait partie
et bicici billets
mais cette vie sinon tout à fait sont
relativement clément vis-à-vis du
président byden et de la politique
démocrate et si vous avez une chaîne qui
met en garde un petit peu contre 7 je
dirais guerre de la désinformation c'est
fox news aujourd'hui où vous avez un
certain nombre d'intervenants qui
essayent de raison garder comme on dit
et c'est d'ailleurs sur cette chaîne que
tu si gabart dont on a parlé cette
représentante démocrate de hawaï
s'étaient exprimés maintenant ce qu'il
faut comprendre aussi c'est que il ya un
intérêt je dirais en termes de politique
intérieure joe biden a bien besoin d'une
distraction et et
comment les élections les élections de
mi mandat et puis vous avez un convoi de
la liberté dont on parle beaucoup au
canada il était question qui est un
convoi de la liberté aux états unis on à
la question de la frontière au texas et
de la frontière avec le mexique qui a
été bafouée considérablement tout au
long de l'année un certain nombre d'élus
républicains bar proche des démocrates
de se soucier beaucoup plus de la
frontière ukrainienne que de la
frontière avec le mexique ce qu'un épais
ce qui n'est pas totalement logique
pourtant il ya aussi beaucoup de
républicains qui souhaitent défendre
l'ukraine en espace
il ya deux positions si vous voulez là
une position qui va de toute façon en
effet défendre l'ukraine mais vous avez
malgré tout une position qui n'est pas
favorable à ce que la situation dégénère
et il n'est pas à mon avis même dans
l'intérêt des démocrates qu'une telle
situation dégénère par contre utiliser
cette situation pour distraire un petit
peu l'opinion de fès économiques et
autres qui ne sont pas forcément
favorables à monsieur bart hayden ça on
comprend très bien pourquoi ils veulent
le faire
eugène berg joe biden n'est pas le seul
il ya aussi jean yves le drian qui s'y
met un bon bah on a toujours reconnu
d'aider des positions assez sévère
envers la russie jean yves le drian qui
dit ce soir rejoindre la position des
états unis il estime que tous les
éléments sont réunis pour une offensive
militaire forte de la russie en ukraine
il ajoute tout de même rien d'un ticket
un petit peu plus prudent que le
président russe ait pris une décision
il est manipulé jean yves le drian ou
lui aussi participe finalement à cette
stratégie qui pourrait peut-être faire
plier moscou comme nous l'expliqué
gérald olivier tout à l'heure
bah je sais pas je pense que tout
bonnement il ya peut-être une
répartition des rôles au président
macron qui est en campagne en
précampagne électorale donc
manifestement d'allant à moscou il prend
un peu de voix un certain trop mouscou
faut pas oublier chacun jour est en
campagne électorale olaf schulze et ces
sondages ont baissé de derrière la cd ou
donc là aussi douillet il n'y a pas que
côté interne politique interne 16 unis a
chez nous mais je crois que l'essentiel
c'est qu'ils se répartissent les rôles
disons à à monsieur le drian qui est
plus âgée de 2 joue un peu le rôle de
père fouettard si je peux mais oplis
expression un peu galvaudé et âme à dieu
le mac ou deux jours le messager de la
paix du médiateur dicton du bon il ya le
bon et demi chance ça fait partie un peu
du western bon mais au-delà de ça je
crois que bien chacun prend des
assurances des contres assurance mais ça
devient évidemment la sens puisque ça
fait des semaines que ça dure on en est
au 4e à 3e acte ou et il faut absolument
que ça se dit ça se résolvent jeu on l'a
dit à plusieurs reprises moi même
personnellement il faudrait que dans les
dix jours à 15 jours on est quelque
chose ou là effectivement aux trois dans
la possibilité de dire mais encore une
fois
bon et ce qui aura invasion est ce
qu'ils auraient incursion sk provocation
vous faisait allusion
la douma qui propose de reconnaître les
républiques autoproclamées ce qui veut
pas dire que ça sera ratifiée par
poutine c'est que ce n'est qu'un moyen
de pression de plus puisque les états
unis font pression et bien les russes
font pression aussi ils ont comme leurs
opinions publiques ils ont quand même
leur préoccupation il faut pas me
prendre il n'y a pas que vladimir
poutine même tout puissante ilec qui est
le vrai pouvoir décisionnel et quand
même taux de force d'autres intérêts
qu'il faut ménager donc là aussi il ya
un jeu qui est complexe mais l'essentiel
c'est qu'il faut passer aux choses
sérieuses c'est à dire en négociation et
la lavrov qui ne m'ont sens qui ne
prenant jamais fait des mots hasard
c'est vraiment un orfèvre il a dit qu'il
faut je répète qu'il faut prolonger
élargir les négociations
donc là il ya quand même à grains
d'espoir et j'espère ce grade donnera
naissance à une fleur comme honneur à la
saint-valentin qu'on pourrait offrir à
nos compagnes
on va ça ce qui est très important à
souligner je suis relativement d'accord
c'est que faut pas perdre de vue la
raison réelle de ce qui se passe en ce
moment en ukraine dire que le sujet
c'est pas l'ukraine le sujet c'est le
temps ce qui ce qui fait peur hein
jardinières poutine ce n'est pas du tout
l'ukraine c'est la position de l'otan et
l'idée de l'avenir continent fait c'est
d'obtenir une sorte de garantie que
l'ukraine ne deviendra jamais un membre
de l'otan si vous prenez la position
américaine
la position des démocrates au contraire
c'est de justifier la nécessité de la
poursuite de l'existence de l'otan je
rappelle qu'il ya quelques années entre
en campagne électorale le candidat
donald trump avait remis en cause la
nécessité de l'otan et avait avait su si
tu avais et émis l'idée d'un
rapprochement avec la russie le
président macro lui même à un moment a
dit que l'otan était totalement obsolète
voilà en mort cérébrale c'était troc y
avait dit qu'il est obsolète alors
attendez pas ce que parce que c'est vrai
que ce que vient de nous dire général de
milliers c'est très intéressant parce
que je vais vous donner la parole aux
jeunes des grands dans quelques instants
volodymyr zelensky aujourd'hui
évidemment à souffler sur les braises ce
n'est pas une surprise mais il a redit à
l'occasion de sa rencontre avec olaf
scholz qu'il voulait que son pays
appartiennent à l'otan que ça garantir
et notre sécurité et la sécurité de de
l'ukraine quand on sait que c'est la
ligne rouge russe voilà c'est pas non
plus de nature à calmer les choses john
baird ça
bah je sais pas d'où vous tenez ma chère
cette information me chercher moi
j'entends du montet la conférence de
presse cet après midi entre voile et des
miens sarens qui est olaf scholz il a
réitéré samedi ses demandes oui
absolument absolument bon parce que moi
j'ai eu l'information à la radio russe
le quai comme sérieuse 1 qui a dit
qu'effectivement un peu le contraire
qu'en disant qu' on ne mettrait pas ça
en avant comme objectif ils sont
d'ambassadeur à londres ça fait l'objet
d'une polémique il a dit justement
l'ambassadeur ukrainien à londres en
disant écoutez c'est pas le moment de
souleilles preuve de l'otan ça peut
attendre et ou alors il s'est fait taper
sur les doigts mais on peut pas et sur
un ballon d'essai on lui a demandé de
dire ça pour ensuite le contrarier donc
il ya aussi un jeu multiple à kiev entre
les différentes m'enfin je vous écoute
si vous avez vraiment entendu sa balle à
mclean
japonais d'abord bon on a compris la
même chose
oui j'ai lu la même dépêche et j'ai vu
le même extrait de conférence de presse
on comprend très bien pourquoi l'ukraine
veut devenir membre de l'otan ils ont
raison c'est un véritable parapluie par
contre c'est vrai que ce n'était pas
réellement sur la table c'est là où
d'ailleurs il faut regarder un petit peu
la politique un peu plus loin parce que
malgré tous les exercices militaires
russes ils sont réels les le
positionnement des troupes russes à la
frontière ukrainienne il est réel les
exercices que sont en train de mener
biélorusses et russes en commun ils sont
réels et donc il ya eu de la part de la
russie une décision volontaire de faire
monter la pression et je pense que là on
a une attitude qui à mon avis a tiré
certaines leçons du désastre et de la
débâcle américaine en afghanistan où
l'administration américaine est apparue
très très faible ce qui a donné à dans
les moeurs poutine un prétexte d'
essayer d'en profiter là les américains
ont réussi jeudi relativement habilement
d'un point de vue diplomatique a
renversé un petit peu la situation
justement en faisant monter la pression
mais je pense que cette crise aurait pu
ou n'aurais dû ne jamais se produire en
tout cas washington un compte offrir
jusqu'à un milliard de dollars de
garanties de crédit à kiev on vient de
l'apprendre et l instant également la
russie n'envahira pas l'ukraine sauf si
on nous provoque un c'est ce que dit
l'ambassadeur russe auprès de l'union
européenne alors ça c'est toujours la
même chose sauf si on nous provoquent
justement et bien voilà qui provoque qui
s'est toujours la question dans cette
affaire aux jeunes berg parce qu'une une
flamme et vite allumé à la frontière où
il ya des militaires de part et d'autre
tout de même on le rappelle quand même
oui non c'est vrai il faut pas oublier
que les russes étaient leurs thèses
constant de dire que vous les
occidentaux vous nous pointer du doigt
parce qu'on passe et les eaux mais vous
ne pointe pas du doigt l'armée
ukrainienne et les extrémistes
ukrainiens comme has ofpra kravis
secteur qui est prêt à prendre de force
d'une basse et lougansk ça aussi ça fait
partie comme il faut ouvrir un peu les
yeux même si c'est disproportionné mais
donc les occidentaux en livrant des
armes offensives les javelots
hélicoptères des tanks vous armée
l'armée ukrainienne qui enfin où une
partie des forces ukrainienne qui volent
à employer la force puisque boutines le
dif est dans la constitution ukrainienne
ilia à l'est la russie est un ennemi pi2
on reprendra en fin de texte quasi
constitucion on va reprendre la crimée
par la force donc tout ça alors même si
on le prend pour une propagande pour
pour dédé jdd déclaration c'est quand
même des menaces donc il faut il faut
j'ai toujours dit il faut que les
occidentaux aussi demande à kiev
d'appliquer les accords de minsk et de
ne pas jeter de l'huile sur le feu c'est
ça la désescalade elle doit être je
l'avais dit elle doit être proportionnée
et simultanées alors évidemment s'il ya
un effort ukrainien qui sera suivi d'un
défaut russe on rentre dans la danse
escalade malheureusement
une semaine après le voyage du président
dacron à moscou on a pratiquement fait
15 mm alors que j'allais faire un maître
mais la presse oublie parce qu' à
l'instant on apprend que l'ukraine a été
informée à on en sait un peu plus sur ce
fameux mercredi l'ukraine a été informée
qu'elle serait attaquée par la russie le
mercredi 16 février
c'est ce qu'a annoncé le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky et c'est
cnn évidemment qui donne cette
information
oui mais ce qui est encore un peu pour
en revenir à votre toute première
question on n'a pas eu connaissance de
du renseignement p6 qui permettent d'en
arriver à ces notions figurant mais
c'est vrai que ça passe par l'ukraine
par le président ukrainien qui aulas qui
soutient cnn c'était également une
demande du président ukrainien qui la
semaine dernière avait émis une
déclaration en disant si les états unis
ont des renseignements précis concernant
une attaque possible qui nous les
communiquent donc à mon avis et c'est la
réponse à cette question mais on n'a pas
le contenu de ce renseignement précis ça
nous rappelle la guerre en irak
peut-être quand on a demandé
désespérément des preuves d'armes de
destruction massive qu'on a jamais donné
où mon esprit ces gars totalement con
n'est pas tout à fait là j'emmène il ya
moins sur la question tu es lancer une
guerre sur la base où il est d'un
mensonge dans ce qui est ce qui est
préoccupant c'est ce que vous et que ce
que vous évoquez à quelques minutes
c'est à dire une étincelle qui viendrait
de quelque part ou peut-être même une
fausse information ou une fausse attaque
qui pourrait donner cause un prétexte
pour qui une réalisation derrière etc
etc c'est ça qui est le plus dangereux
évidemment j'aime bien le mot de la fin
pour vous
bah écoutez c'est un peu contradictoire
parce que monsieur zielinski a dit vous
faites une hystérie sur yon locale le
mot de la fin je vais le donner au
général de gaulle c'est en pleine crise
de berlin l'ambassadeur suivi tic et
elle est le voir en disant si vous ne
cédez pas et bien dans une guerre et on
va alors le général de gaulle s'est levé
il ay monsieur ambassadeur nous mourrons
ensemble
donc voilà je crois qu'il faut garder la
tête froide et il faut il faut décanter
les choses on verra le 16 et pourquoi
pas 10 7 pour pas 18 donc c'est sérieux
je crois que l'on s'est pas lieu de
faire l'humour mais je crois que c'est
les historiens auront beaucoup à dire
parce que là on arrive comme disent les
russes à degré d'hystérie peu connu dans
les relations internationales on négocie
en même temps on dit on va attaquer quoi
c'est quelque chose qui est au delà de
l'entendement donc on verra bon
attendons au love child qui alors
prudents qui a consulté angela merkel
qui est aussi qu'elle connaît très bien
vladimir poutine
les allemands paient ils ont quand même
beaucoup d'intérêt on n'a pas eu le
temps d'en parler aujourd'hui on en
parlera peut-être deux ou trois quatre
jours là aussi c'est quand même une
mission très importante encore une fois
qu'elle fait en pleine coordination
entre l'elysée puis le bundestag sera et
quoi là aussi donc l'europe revient et
c'est très intéressant vous allusion à
l'irak vous savez les trois pays france
allemagne russie se sont opposées à
l'intervention des états unis et l'irak
est ce cette trouille cas alors elle
n'existe pas encore mais il n'est pas
impossible qu'ils aient une volonté de
lui donner une petite vie une petite
flamme en disant oui il ya quand même
trois pays qui sont les trois grands
pays européens la russie l'allemagne et
la france qui peuvent faire quelque
chose alors que les anglo saxons eux ils
jettent de l'huile sur le feu ils sont
les alarmistes ils veulent reconstituer
l'otan donc là aussi il ya cet aspect
qu'il faut c'est pas uniquement comme
l'ukraine
c'est toute cette géopolitique
européenne et mondiale qui est en jeu
donc voyez c'est quelque chose je crois
qui fondait le conscient et encore
analysé dans un dans un cadre plus large
plus large ici d'où le parallèle
évidemment puisque la situation n'est
pas comparable
malgré tout des américains font monter
l'hystérie parce qu'il met en garde
contre une invasion possible mais là il
n'est pas question pour l'instant d'une
quelconque intervention américaine en
ukraine ça c'est pas du tout le sujet
voilà on en n'est pas là c'est on est
d'accord on est on est bien d'accord
merci à tous les deux jeunes berg
général de l'idée d'avoir été avec nous